[Music]
you have creative fans you know it's we
live in an era where if you have
creative fans you're actually able to
find out about it because of the
internet you have fans that have come up
with something called what is it is it
Julia Stiles hangs onto stuff is that
right yeah it's so random I'm very
flattered Julia Julia Julia Stiles on or
on things yeah and it's you like hanging
onto things and they're all if not like
me on drugs or on no no no no like it's
me why you'd bring that up literally yes
you Emma we found just as just two
examples I think there's one of you
hanging off the Spice Girls
[Laughter]
you just love it you're desperately
desperately hanging on I think it'll let
me go to posh yeah and then there's one
of you hanging off of keyboard cat
another reason why China is kicking our
ass I know what's that I love that I
love it we have something to talk about
which is you shot the makeover which is
this television project that you that
you've worked on the you're promoting
you shot it in this correct in Boston my
hometown yes yes in Boston
we went all over Boston lots of really
great locations I love Boston it's a
great city I I love that town and for
the thank you one guy oh thank you thank
you two guys it is and the premise of
the movie is it's sort of a modern-day
my fair lady is that right now you're
you're the I'm the Henry Higgins
character and it's like my fair lady
Pygmalion I play a girl who has it's
kind of an upstart and she's run for
Congress in Boston and she loses that's
the opening scene but she finds a
working-class Boston guy with the very
thick accent to kind of make over into
the perfect candidate so she can have
him run in the reelection so as part of
the prejudices you're trying to him get
him to clean up his Boston accent yeah
he loses his boxes busts thick heavy
Boston accent you know wicked pissah
that sort of thing i i'm i played my
mother talks by the way
Gina swallows yes so you had a lot of
scenes where you had to do the Boston
accent which is well no I'm the one who
has like perfect grammar so I'm walking
around almost practically British
although it wasn't British saying things
like I don't know to which I don't know
to whom you are referring that kind of
annoying right so he and then you know
it's men and women so romance ensues he
gets me to kind of loosen up and and and
she gets him to mmm
just lose the accent really you know
mission accomplished
that's enough I grew up around that
accent that's a rough you know it's
funny I don't even know what happened
but when my parents my dad took
you know like Super eight film when we
were kids and we look at it and I'm like
yeah yes dansgame yeah and then I think
I moved away fairly young and lived in a
lot of different cities and it just went
away I never made an effort to get rid
of it but when I'm a kid
yeah like theatrical training he didn't
god no look at me
let's talk about oh yeah can you do the
accent you know I you know it's funny I
can't even do it and when I hosted
starting out live years ago I was in a
sketch where I supposed to do the Boston
accent and they were trying to train me
to do the Boston accent and I couldn't
do it I had like a mental block so I
grew up with it and I had it till I was
8 and then it went away and I'm
incapable of it oh that was like that
sketch with um with Jimmy Fallon right
the the Red Sox and yes you are yeah
yeah yeah I forget it was in the 1930s
was when Sir nut life was primarily a
radio show a bunch of young people were
thinking I didn't know that